we've already looked at
very briefly what happens when the
integrator is not a log function
but you end up with one okay so now
we're going to tackle these
all right
now with the exception of this first one
these almost all fall under the category
of those questions where it's like
differentiate this
some weird thing you've never seen
before and then you'll get something and
use that result
to form an integral okay i've got a few
examples over here but you can sort of
just make them up
really um i said though with the
exception of this first one so have a
look at it stare it with me
okay i think you can all actually with
enough help you can see
that it's actually an integral that you
know exactly what to deal with
now the first clue is there's a fraction
right
now when you see a fraction you ought to
think that's sort of ought to lead you
in a direction for what kind of
primitive you ought to get when you
evaluate the integral
okay we've already been dealing with
fractions so far
right what kinds of fractions have we
been dealing with generally speaking
we're looking for the numerator to be
related to the denominator in a specific
way what is it
it's the derivative isn't it
if we have this kind of setup we're fine
okay
so the question is how can i squeeze
this
into a kind of shape that'll match this
you've got very limited pieces to work
with right for instance
that log x right you can't really move
it anywhere
yeah now you could take the x log x and
think
i wonder what the derivative of x log x
might be okay you could take that part
okay
but there's a simpler way look at it
carefully
remember i told you that that log x
can't really go anywhere right
what's the derivative of log x again
it's 1 over x if only we could get a 1
over x
on the numerator
wait a second we do have a 1 over x
on the numerator don't we because
division
1 over x or 1 divided by it's the same
thing
okay so i'm going to take that x that x
right there
dividing by x i can put it wherever i
like really
if it's equivalent i'm going to put it
on the numerator
whatever x all divided by
log x and that's
f dash on f f dash on f
now by the way just as a quick note some
of you
i will write it like this okay let's see
because this is this is one of the ways
that you can write
reverse channel if you like and some
textbooks will do it this way
some people will write it like this
sorry i know that's a bit light but
hopefully you can read it right
so people will say with that thing on
the top that's my f dash right
so write it as d which means kind of
differentiate
of log x okay so this kind of makes that
f dash on the f
kind of obvious yeah now i think that's
okay
i generally try and steer clear of it
the reason why is
when you get lots of d's flying around
it gets confusing don't even get me
started when we're talking about related
rates of change
if i can avoid writing more ds
i will i think that's actually kind of
more confusing unless you're really used
to it
so if you really want to have something
like that i think your best alternative
is to say that that's in the form
which which is equivalent to f dash
sorry integral of f dash on f
where f equals
log x okay i kind of think it's a bit
excessive especially for one as simple
as this i think you can kind of see it
but if you want to make sure that you
get reverse chain rule right if you have
something a little more complicated here
then go ahead and write this step on the
side so that it clarifies you're working
okay now that aside
i can now say this is log of
f isn't it which in this case is
actually itself
log x so it's kind of like
you know i heard you like
integrating so i put a blog in your logs
anyway
that's it you're done i can't draw the
guy with the hair
anyway but that's that's pretty simple
okay that's about as simple as it gets
for something which has a log function
in the integrand
and you'll end up with a log function on
the other side in fact you more or less
always get
if you're on a log on the left you'll
get along on the right as well okay
now like i said the rest of these
questions fall under the category of
differentiate this
and then hints and degrade so take b c
and d okay
i'll walk you through b and then i'll
get you a c and d on your own
differentiate it and then form a
statement about an integral
okay so let me walk you through it for b
what have i got so differentiate
that
okay and in a second we'll make a
statement about integration okay
so what do we got uh this is just
product rule isn't it
okay so you can write it as v
sorry that's just an x v times u dash
plus u times
v dash well okay
minus just this guy right but that's
just one
uh sorry no yeah that's all product okay
so you've got log x here
plus the x's cancel minus one
so what you get is that okay
so the derivative of this
is this so now i'm going to integrate
both sides with respect to x
okay so if i integrate this side
with respect to x i'll undo the
differentiation that i did on this side
so you'll just get x log x minus x
plus your constants that's kind of cool
the integral of log x is that okay
so there's a statement based on how i
differentiated
okay so have a go at doing c and d
you'll also notice i've got
actual concrete numbers in there like
five minus one and seven okay
after you have a go at doing c and d i
reckon you could generalize
you could probably turn that into a x
plus b
log a x plus b
minus a x so you could find a rule
for a form of integral from there and
this you don't have to put a seven i
reckon once you see the way seven works
you'll see the way it works with any um
real number really
so after you've had to go at cd i put in
numbers to just make it easier for you
to process but after you've done it with
numbers
see if you can generalize to any kinds
of constant
coefficients and constant terms okay
all right give it a go